today's a special day finale no you got
the key to niagara falls i did i'm
learning this now i didn't know that
yeah i got that they presented me the
mayor the mayor presented me with the
key to niagara falls really cool to be
honest with you i was making some jokes
and things but it really meant a lot to
me this town this city means so much to
me because as a kid growing up this is
the place i came to have fun this is my
spot and to be honored in my home
province in my home country in the most
fun place i ever went was so great and
it's not only key a local artist painted
on the key so it's a piece of art it's a
key and last night we went to ihop and
listen
let me finish the story before you say
no way
but today i got the key to the city so
it doesn't matter what time i get there
i can always open it up okay
so that would have been funny if the
timing was right if you hadn't screamed
in the middle oh i messed it up it's not
that funny it wasn't even worth it i
think you upgraded it right right look
at her judging
now that you have the keys and simon
cowell is coming to guest judge are you
going to take him around niagara falls
because he's never been here before has
he never been everything he's never been
here he's never been here before
niagara falls here is where we are here
is always here i understand that but
here could mean canada and then i was
going to really judge
i think he's been to canada but he's
never been to niagara falls so we rented
bikes and i'm taking them around are you
what's the key
well the big deal is the bikes he falls
off by interviews you not believing
anything he says just so we're all so
confused right now
welcome to my world
you're judging again that is true i am a
judge okay
well what do you think simon will think
about this whole thing because i he told
me
that he didn't want to know anything
ahead of time he wanted to call him and
tell him what was going on will he be
surprised by the talent that he's going
to see here in canada good question
um the truth is i will say no and this
is why i will say no because
our some of our favorite acts in the
history of agt and i can't speak for bgt
because i haven't been there have been
homegrown canadians and i have been
really disappointed that i'm going
you're here why don't they have it there
and then finally they're there so now
he's seeing where this talent has come
from i love that
i gotta say i love watching you i love
your reactions you are so amazing isn't
she she really my wife even said oh my
god lily is the the star you you're here
no you really are star i got this shirt
too man
i just said that because as i'm watching
on tv yeah i told myself one thing going
into the show which was don't try
because how he gave me this advice don't
put on a facade react how you would
react be yourself
give them truthful feedback and so when
i was watching myself reacting i was
like oh this is me genuinely me because
i have like the stang face going on i'm
like grooving and i was like semi
embarrassed but i'm like no you know
that's genuine that's actually me so i'm
glad you've been enjoying it yeah and
you know i think that part of it is too
because you're you're in the judges
table and you get to see these talent
come out and they have that spark in
their eyes they they have that passion
and they want that dream to come true
how does that feel to be able to see
that moment for these channels it's
really special and as someone who has
been on the stage as well and nobody
feels like to be judged i really do feel
for our contestants and i wish the best
for them like as i'm watching them so
badly in my heart i'm like please i want
you to do so well i want you to go off
the stage and say you had fun and so it
really is a deep connection that's being
formed even though we're judging and
even though they're performing i feel
like we're one of the same but from the
moment that they walk out on stage and
show up on this show you can feel
because we are all performers as she
said you could feel the nervousness and
the tension and they look out they're on
the biggest stage in the world and
they're looking out and all these
cameras and they know millions of people
are going to see them but that moment of
when it clicks and they know they've
done well and everybody stands up and
everybody's cheering you are actually
watching somebody's dream come to
fruition it doesn't feel real it feels
like a dream and it's real and i always
tell people you get it at home and
people love it and tears come out but
here it is so strong we have the best
job in the world and the best seats in
the house i'll tell you what i was
watching at home savio uh i don't know
if it was like the brown person connect
and i know no i felt the same way with
it
yeah because he said yes but but he said
this was the last chance if this didn't
work out for him he was going to go into
computer science or whatever that i was
like watching that i was like wow this
is really a big big deal and so it's
really special can you believe it's the
finale like this is it i'm also so sad
though because i love these guys so much
we text all the time all the judges are
like close friends lindsay included the
host and we love each other so much i've
missed them i never got a text he's in
the textbook all he texts is the word
meme he won't send to me he respects the
word meme
so
these kids with their social media
but that that is true you guys are this
is the finale you're gonna have to say
bye to the team for a bit
season two we'll be back are you going
for tears
no i just i feel it i feel being here
you're gonna give me tears i am because
you get to go to high hop and i mean
like this is an emotional moment it is
this is it this is the end of the season
oh my god do you know who's gonna win do
you have a favorite
i personally do you do i do okay i don't
want to say it out loud because it's up
to canada but i believe they're
i and i'm usually right i'm right on the
american show yes
i believe it's right we did talk about
it we did and we both said it correct
let's not sh we're not going to share i
don't want to share it because i don't
want to make it unfair because
ultimately they're going to vote and
don't i don't want we think doesn't
matter also but also i don't want to
sway anybody you've got to choose it
without our input now how you've been
season 17 now over agt you've been doing
this for a while a long time how do you
define talent
wow oh that's a good question
you don't that's the point you don't and
i think people are too harsh too i don't
they're and that's the beauty of these
got talent shows because
what is talent is talent you know we had
a guy the the the example that i give is
on america's got talent we had a guy
named horse
that was his name and his his talent or
his act was uh being kicked in the
nether regions
right nobody ended up with an mtv show
so because there's people that want to
see jackass there's people that want to
see that so what i'm saying is whatever
you do and if we should be lucky enough
to have another season i say that to
people
don't judge yourself whatever it is you
do you just gotta show up and i think
that's a good template for life you just
show up you do it and when you i didn't
everything i've ever been punished for
expelled for hit for is what i get paid
for this was not considered a talent i
don't have a ged for doing what i do and
get paid for i love that now lily
simon's name is good i love that good
job you're surprised by the fact that i
was able oh i'm not surprised
together i just that was good
you said good work you said good work
your name is next to simon i see that
have you met simon and are you nervous
are you excited
never have met simon okay obviously i've
watched him on tv uh i'm excited to meet
him i i won't lie i'm a little bit
intimidated but to be honest you didn't
i was intimidated the first time at
howie i'm intimidated yeah the first
time how do you feel standing right next
to me feel like we need to go to ihop
like
i sat next to her and i was a little
intimidated someone who has done this
for so long that's a pro at this and now
i'm in between howie and simon so i feel
like if anything i'm just gonna walk
away upgrade it a little bit because
that's how i feel after sitting next to
howie i tell everyone this all jokes
aside i've learned so much from howie i
feel like he has really helped me with
my on-screen presence he's helped me be
myself on camera and i think i must
learn but i believe that canada is going
to love the sing sandwich
sing sandwich yeah internet have fun
with that
one well congratulations good luck
tonight i hope the person you think is
going to win will win if they don't it
won't be terrible but i'd be terrible
but you know this person deserves it
everybody who's on the finale deserves
to win but only one can
how about we put our houses on it
you have a big house right let's do that
can you whisper to me who's gonna win
yeah okay do you really yeah
oh really i missed it
good luck tonight have fun thank you you
guys are awesome
you